[Music]
all right let's run out to Indianapolis
and talk to allora that's probably the
radest name of anyone on the show ever
what's up
allora hey what's up is that hey what's
up is is your name allora really yes
dude what a beautiful beautiful name
that's awesome all right so what's up
how can I
help so my first like main question is
how do I get my husband to see that you
know being a stay-at-home mom isn't just
an easy task of doing just simple
things what's your secondary
question um how do I get him to treat me
more like a wife and not just someone to
communicate with when he wants
sex that is the
question so anytime somebody asks me how
do I get my husband to to um see me as a
stay-at-home mom or someone who's
working part-time and we got three kids
or whatever
um I'm going to walk through like The
Temptations here and then we'll get to
your question is that cool use this as
like a moment to teach a little bit um
so like one one idea is you can just go
out of town for a week and just let him
like stay at home and figure it out
right that happened to me early on when
we only had one kid and by day too I
didn't know what day it was I didn't
know what time it was like everything
was just everywhere and um there was
like Taco Bell rappers growing out of
the coffee table and stuff it was just
chaos um so that's the Temptation number
one right is I'll show you I'll prove it
to you Temptation number two is um I'm
going to make you a minute by minute I'm
going to make you like a list of my
things I do every day and we're going to
compare lists you what you do at work
versus what I do here um and we're going
to do that that's also a Temptation I
don't think that's effective here
because what you're talking about is
honor and dignity and trust it is not
about
um uh strategy and calendar preparation
okay and your second question is the
most important one and I think your
first question about how do I convince
my husband that what I'm doing is
actually
hard man that's a way distant second
question too
how do I get my husband to treat me like
a human
being yeah when did that
start it's been since our daughter
was born before that things were great
but after that he just kind of you know
threw me to the side if he wants sex
he'll communicate otherwise it's I'll
ask him what he wants for dinner and
it's I don't care or you know he won't
talk to me in person either it's always
through like Facebook messenger through
text like there's no actual
communication between
us okay two important things here number
one on one area I don't fully believe
you okay and know that I'm on your team
okay yeah but this is it's very very
rare that somebody flips a switch like
this he's probably been a jerk for a
long time is that fair or no yeah yeah
before kid before
baby yeah
yeah so why'd you end up with
him I it was basically through being
hurt not having a dad growing up and you
know just I was on the verge of leaving
him before our daughter was born but
when I found out I was pregnant I was
like I don't want my child to grow up
without her dad like I did your daughter
is growing up without her dad he just
happens to live in the same
house your daughter's also getting a
ringside seat into how a terrible human
being treats a
woman a woman that he stood before his
friends and his family and God and said
I do
forever and I'm not surprising you
though I mean you know this right yeah
so you said you grew up without a dad
was was growing up hard
yeah I was adopted so I was basically
raised in a family with medically
Fragile Kids I was the only one normal
you know so I was kind of just left
myself okay most of my
life how old are
you
24 so we're going to have a real scary
conversation is that
okay yeah CU I know you've thought this
through and my promise is I'm going to
be honest okay this is the part when
people listening to the
show start yelling just leave him what
are you doing why don't you just move
out
right yeah and that's the moment when
the 24-year-old
mom who's been a stay-at-home mom who's
been beaten down her entire
life says yeah but how do I eat and how
do I pay rent where am I going to
go yeah so my question for you is where
would you
go probably back to New Mexico where my
family is is that a safe place to go for
a season to get your feet underneath
you yes and no I mean I'm still kind of
beat down by that side of my family I
always have been cuz I wasn't the you
know the girly girl or the girl that
went and got a degree in nursing to them
like the rest of my family was or you
know you do have a degree in nursing or
you didn't get one I didn't both my
sisters and my mom did okay all right so
you're taking a different path and when
you take a different path a it looks
cool on Instagram and B in real life
taking your own path is hard right it's
just harder and that's cool it's just
it's just more of a struggle
um I'm going to go as far to say based
on what you're telling me about him you
are not in a safe position is that fair
your home safe
yeah my home is safe yes other than you
know the the fact that you live with a
grizzly bear won't talk to you yeah so
let me flip this around have you sat
down and talked to him and said hey what
happened I've tried to and he just says
you know basically that I'm making him
sound like a
monster he is a monster
Laura I mean tell me I'm wrong defend
him if he's worth
defending
no are you done with
this yeah you sound done and you know
one of my policies on the show is I
never tell somebody to get divorced
unless they're at uh in in physically or
psychologically UNS safe
um so I can't make that call for
you but I do think it's really really
important that you get with a
professional counselor ASAP to do a
couple of things number one you have to
learn how to stand up on your own two
feet and you
can and I think you've got those skills
because you had to do that growing up in
a house where you were an invisible kid
and also
it's scary right especially being a
single
mom two you're going to have to get some
wisdom and guidance on how to navigate
this relationship whether you try to
save it again or you end up ending it
you're going to need somebody to walk
alongside you
okay okay I also know that stuff costs
money so I'm going to give you three
months with my friends at better help
for free okay okay and but you got to
promise me that you'll use
it yeah I will and that might only be a
bridge to get you to a counselor in town
okay and um but you got to promise that
you're going to do it and it's can be
weekly counseling that you can do via
your phone you can do on on um the
computer right on Zoom or whatever
however you want to set it up but you
got to promise me that you'll do it will
you yeah yes okay another thing I'm
going to send you for your home I'm
going to send you um Financial Peace
University in the every dollar app for a
year here's why I'm doing that two
things number one I've seen it happen
over and over and over again that
talking about budgets forces couples to
sit at a
table sitting at a table may not be safe
for you and that's okay if it's not but
talking about money means you have to
talk about what are our values and what
do we want to do and what are our dreams
and what kind of house do we want to
live in what kind of home do we want to
have and what kind of vacations we want
to go on it forces you to have those
conversations about values and goals and
unification or parts where you're like
yeah I'm I'm out you have to come to the
table on that and my little end around
here is also it's going to give you some
skills that you don't have about
managing money making money how
insurance and all that stuff works that
you probably aren't aren't up up to up
to skill on but it's going to give you
some insights into what life would be
like if you end up going back to New
Mexico for a season okay okay so hang on
the line I'm going to send all that
stuff to you
in all I need you to hear me walk away
with this number one you're not
crazy you're not
crazy it is I I don't blame any guy who
just got married who's working really
hard and he gets home because it
happened to me I'd get home from work
and my wife would just hand me our kit
and she by the way she was working
full-time so that just shows you what an
ignorant [__] I was but she would just
hand me the kid and my first thought was
whoa I just got home from work you know
how tired I am that would be first
thought that's just me being honest and
I learned over in short order oh my
fatigue is pretend fatigue compared to
what she's working through right it's
not real it actually super was real but
it was we had to figure it out right so
I'm not ever going to fault a guy for
being like what do you do all day that's
a that's an honest question that if we
don't ask that question then what
happens is you end up being quiet about
it you end up getting building up
resentment and that's stupid
and that is different a that's a
different question to hey what happens
here all day is different
than I don't talk to my wife I just talk
to her on Facebook Messenger like a
child I only contact her when I want sex
I don't interact with my CH with my new
baby that has nothing to do with how do
I convince my husband that I've got
value that I'm doing stuff during the
day I say this often on the show and
I'll end the call with
this behavior is a
language so often we try to get people
to talk to us and they don't talk they
don't have the communication the ability
to talk we we we like hey will you sit
on and talk to me you sit on and talk to
me and really through their actions
they've been loud and
clear and in a situation like this I can
ask like hey I want to talk to that guy
see if your marriage is over or behavior
is a language he is being very clear he
has no interest in being married to her
he's interested in having someone to
sleep with every once in a while he's
interested in having uh a a livein
housekeeper he is not interested in
being married or having a wife doing
life with somebody behavior is a
language I hate this for you Allura
we'll be with you every step of the way
call any time um please please reach out
to my friends at better help um I got
you for three months please reach out to
them um you're going to need somebody in
your corner because it's going to be a
long scary road but you got
this